all right so
will and i's marriage did not end one
day it took time to get there and you do
the work
you had to do that in front of everybody
but it's the same
and
i am disappointed when people judge that
and don't understand especially when
there are children involved i think
everything is different when you have
children i think you know the very fact
that i wasn't even 12 weeks pregnant i
mean yes the first time it happened with
anthony the story broke number one i was
still deeply in love with my husband i
was also in shock i also didn't
understand the behavior but
yes it would have been so much easier to
just walk away except that we share this
child together and i walked in so much
shame for so long i write a whole
chapter about this feeling like the
elephant in the room not knowing where i
was welcome it's just a horrible feeling
i think a lot of women feel like they're
judged okay you just brought up a really
trigger key point shame
i have a circumstance that i thought of
you
i was
walking out of my ob gyn and um i had
just found out i was pregnant and um i
walked out of her office
and someone i work with chris miller got
all these calls we know she's pregnant
we're breaking the story he's like you
guys always talk like this we're at a no
comment group come on you're being silly
and they're like well take a look at
this and it's the picture and i was
stupid enough to carry the sonogram in
my hand
out with me i was depressed
or saddened kind of that i didn't get to
um
have that be a private thing a moment or
just to wrap my head around it
is it true that you one of your
toughest phone calls was of all that you
had to deal with
was about your pregnancy
i was uh
i don't wanna say eight weeks pregnant
the story i tell about being in
buckingham palace three days later the
story breaks about anthony being in
communication online with other women
and two days later i get a phone call
from my friend philippe he said this is
a very awkward conversation for me but
you know the new york times has called
and they're about to report that you're
pregnant and um
is there anything you want to share he
obviously didn't know and i was so mad i
had so much rage i felt like this deep
the secret i hadn't told anybody i told
we told our parents and our siblings
and so um he said do you want to you
know do you want to tell hillary do you
want to call people i said no i dare
them i dare them to run this story i'm
not even 12 weeks pregnant and of course
they did
and i was so shattered i was so broken
by not being able to share what for me
was a once in a lifetime gift yes that
till today today and i did it yesterday
in the kitchen that i wander around and
when i'm in the shower or shopping i'll
just say i'm pregnant
and i say it because i never got to say
it
before um
and yesterday jordan said to me mommy
you're pregnant
and i'm like no no no no and but it it
reminds you that there are things
that do stay with you i so appreciate
hearing that because it's not
always what you expect is the moment
here's what i mean
so when i got that phone call from chris
miller of
i gotta tell you something something is
coming out
um it wasn't the pregnancy i feared it
was being caught drinking
and i felt like
this was my shame
and i was almost relieved when it wasn't
that
when people find out your deepest
darkest secrets and i experienced that
when i was 13 years old
and got outed and thrown into an
institution and career over i was i i
have such ptsd from that
that i think if someone's going to catch
me drinking again i'm going to lose my
career to lose my job that i love so
much
and it's so traumatizing and that was my
thing and it carries with it so much
shame
how did you
deal with that the first time anthony
and i sat down after his first you know
the first revelation about his
communication with women online
i felt and we went away we went to texas
to therapy i didn't understand anything
i didn't understand anything about you
know behavior that you couldn't control
i didn't understand addiction i didn't
know anybody growing up really who was
divorced or split up we these weren't
things you talked about in the middle
east
and i felt like the minute it was all
out
he seemed so relieved he was like almost
like an unburdening and he said well how
do i stop the behavior and how do i fix
it and i fully believed he could knock
it off 100 thought in 2011 when this
first happened he could just stop and
then we learned later when he ran for
mayor of new york city in 2013 when
there was another revelation that he
clearly couldn't stop it so every time i
would get a call whether it was from
anthony or philippe as we talked about
everything was a call or a text saying
this tabloid called or i have to tell
you something it is how bad is it and
and living with in this world of it's
not going to be as bad as i think it is
it's going to be worse because it always
was
and that's why in 2019 and i do share
the story in the book of really when i
got to the end of my i couldn't you know
i contemplated stepping off a subway
platform it was really my low of the low
and when i did that there were two
things that came really came to me was
number one
all of this holding everything and all
of this anger and bitterness was only
hurting me is something i later learned
with anthony in therapy is that while
pain might be necessary suffering is
optional we have to go to another
commercial really quickly but we will be
right back
[Music]